I can't believe your husband proposed to
you on the set of pet
cemetery what the [__] well it wasn't on
the set we went away for the weekend to
the beautiful Acadia National Park okay
so it wasn't on the set of pet cemetery
got Fred no my husband's so romantic he
he had you know bought he' bought a ring
you know and he was looking for a time
and a place and so we went away for the
weekend up to the national park and we
never actually he wanted to like propose
to me at Sunrise which is the first
place that the sun rises in America is
at aadia National Park Cadillac Mountain
what it's the eastern
most Park in America didn't know that
and um so he had this huge plan but like
all
plans well it didn't come to fruition
because he just couldn't bear to wait
that long so he actually proposed to me
like 4 hours after we' left you know El
worth Maine and uh that's where they
they shot pet cemeteries in Ellsworth
which did you by the way I know I'm
jumping around but I'm thinking of Mike
Flanigan and Midnight Club and which is
available on Netflix did you how many
times did you audition for that or he
just offered you the part he just
offered me the part
see I mean that really picked me up out
of a really I mean there's this yeah I
wasn't in a funk but I just didn't think
anything like that was going to happen
um so you just got a call one day or
your agent said hey Mike Flanigan wants
to talk to you well yeah my manager
called and said uh there's a casting
director casting director up here in
Vancouver who contacted me um Mike
Flanigan has a new show and they they
would like to have you read this
part and uh I said great you know send
it over I'm thinking it's like a one
episode thing and really excited about
it but then I got the sides and the
opening speech of this character it was
like one speech and you kind of get to
know Dr Georgina Stanton basically um
her son has died of cancer and she's
opened up a hospice for kids with cancer
who are terminal and this is like it was
just her opening speech where she's
welcoming a new patient into this
hospice and I um I get the I'm in I'm
like literally on the 101 freeway
getting off at Los virgin's Canyon Road
and I decided to pull into the G station
just to read the sides cuz I had to do
the audition the next morning on my
iPhone and I just wanted to like go over
it in my head while I'm driving my long
little windy road over Malibu Canyon so
I sit there and I'm reading the sides
and I just burst into tears like cuz her
story is not my exact story but I lost
my son to brain cancer five years ago
and so this whole this whole idea that
she was this woman who' lost her son and
had decided decided to open a hospice
for kids with cancer was something that
just really struck a nerve in me and so
after I you know cried for several
minutes then I just started like
memorizing the lines like okay I'm going
to just get this in me and so over my
windy road and then the next morning I
had to get up and do an audition and it
took me like I'm so bad at home
auditions but they're terrible I just
set up my lights and and uh you know get
my phone and it's like I'm trying to
figure it out and I do I probably do 40
takes 40 takes I went from like 8:30 in
the morning when I started and then my
manager's calling me at like 3:30 like
where is it it needs to be in they want
it by 5: and I'm like it's coming it's
almost ready I almost have a good one CU
it was such a long Mike Flanigan speech
oh my go and I didn't want to make any
mistakes go I've talked about these
Flanigan speeches with other actors that
have worked with him they're they're na
they do one he likes one or two takes or
and it's just pushing in on you we not
cut away so it was um really
nerve-wracking I didn't know that about
Mike when I had the monologue I just
thought oh they've chosen a monologue
for the audition and when they do that
there's just really no way to make a
mistake and you have like 20 beats you
know you're trying to get out in this
monologue and if you miss one and I'm
like nope got to do it again so like 40
takes and you got the one that you said
this finally I just like this one's it
it was like 3:15 and you know you upload
it get it there and then the next day
they're like great they loved it okay
you know they're going to give you a
contract tonight and and then I saw that
it was for the series you know seven
episodes was you just jumping around the
house screaming I was jumping around the
house screaming and I could not believe
it I couldn't believe that my life had
taken such a wonderful turn you know
because I had been kind of in like this
funk like what am I going to do with
myself and um well someone still sees us
it you know I mean someone still sees it
someone who's a great he's brilliant I
will say Mike is brilliant and a lot of
people agree and for him to say yep I
I've see her and then her Reed you know
you still got it I hope I mean I really
I worked I worked so hard on that show
because there were lots of monologues
and I am you know of a certain age where
memorizing is not as easy as it was when
I was 20 so my um my daughter who lived
in at the time I I had her come over I
hired her every day to go over my lines
and we went you know I would work really
really hard on them so that when I got
to the set that day I knew I would do it
on the first take I would never I would
never expect them to have to do a second
take for me and so I I really wanted to
bring that and you know working with
such young actors too I just wanted to
set a really good example